um I hope everyone enjoyed all of our
treats outside I sure did
um um so I am I'm thrilled to like
introduce our next speaker Laura
um
um brand DMR is that right that's
perfect hey
um um she is she is a faculty at
um
um
Arizona
um and she is in the College of um of
like um
management and and she works extensively
on sort of like privacy from the
perspective of kind of like policy and
management
um so we're very excited to kind of have
her in this perspective of Beyond just
like you know algorithms that are
important but also how do we bring these
algorithms into the real world very much
aligned with the like themes of our talk
um before I turn it over to him Laura
if you have any questions during the
talk raise your hand and I'll bring you
the mic
um and for Zoom folks put your questions
in the chat and then I will like
interrupt Laura as appropriate and we'll
also have some time at the end for some
questions so uh take it away Laura
thank you so much everyone it's such a
pleasure to uh to be here although uh
just just virtually
um so thank you for the invitation and
giving me a chance to share uh some of
uh my research with you guys
um so yes I'm a I'm an assistant
professor of management information
systems at the Eller College of
Management uh here at the University of
Arizona in Tucson and today I'm going to
talk about achieving the simple uh uh
when it comes to privacy management so
if you don't know the reference I
obviously stole it from Barney Stinson
um uh from How I Met Your Mother
um so he says all my life have dared to
go past what is possible to the place
where the possible and the impossible
meet to become the past simple so
nothing and everything is possible and I
think about privacy management a lot
like the plus symbol um in this uh in
this in this past few years I've been
I've been focusing a lot on turning
something that seems impossible into uh
past simple so
um let's start from the impossible part
um and uh so as I said before feel free
to interrupt me at any time I'll also
make sure that I have some um uh that
I'll wait for a couple of seconds every
once in a while so that if you uh if you
have questions
um you can come in
um so on the impossibility of privacy
management
um I've worked a lot on um analyzing
factors that affect people's uh privacy
decision making and uh in my research
with my co-authors uh we identified
several factors that make it virtually
impossible for people to put in place uh
their desired strategies for privacy
management to reach the desired level of
privacy protection uh which from a
policy perspective might even be
considered desirable level of privacy
protection and so I'll go over 10 of
these factors and this is not
um by any means an exhaustive uh list
it's just to give you a sense of really
how difficult it is for people to manage
their privacy
um so we start from economic factors
there's going to be some jargon here
which I'll explain in the next few
slides we'll talk about some of the
economic factors that affect people's
impossibility to manage their privacy
effectively
asymmetric information
simply costs and benefits associated
with Technologies of storage collection
and use of data and something that some
economists have called the Privacy
calculus
and there's other types of factors as
well psychological and evolutionary
factors that also make it really really
difficult for us to manage our privacy
properly we'll talk about the desire to
share and all the benefits around
sharing
adaptation so the fact that people are
really good at simply adapting to any
condition that they're in and also risk
perception how humans evolved to detect
risks
um and then also as a subgroup of
psychological factors that affect
privacy decision making
um I'll talk about specific human biases
and limitations which can be easily
exploited uh by any
um organization that essentially has
interests in doing so
um I'll mention the control Paradox
something that we named the control
Paradox in one of our earlier papers
um some herding behaviors some default
bias as well as
um emotional reactions
um and I have those three dots at the
end basically again to emphasize that
this is by no means an exhaustive list
but these are only some of the factors
that we have looked into
um extensively so let's start from the
economics right
um so asymmetric information essentially
asymmetric information is economic
jargon simply to say that whenever there
is an interaction or a transaction
between two parties one of the parties
has more information about the good
product or service that is being uh sold
or exchanged as compared to the other
party
um in the context of privacy management
we have on the one hand the individual
who is mostly unaware of the risks
associated with sharing information and
on the other side corporations
organizations that know perfectly well
the entity of
um or the extent I should have said the
extent to which data is exchanged sold
what are the risks what are the benefits
so unfortunately people cannot avoid
negative outcomes that they are unaware
of and so recent surveys by the Pew
Research Center this dates back to 2019
have over and over emphasized the idea
that people have no no idea how their
data is collected how their data is used
how it is treated this is both true at
the governmental level as well as the
commercial level so people essentially
don't know uh very little or no very
little about how either the government
or commercial organizations use uh their
data what data they collect and for how
long they retain it under what
conditions and so on and so forth
there's extreme confusion in the general
public about what happens to their data
which obviously leads to the
impossibility for people to make
informed decisions they simply don't
have the right amount of information
and when they do sometimes it's
basically too late so sometimes we
discover the costs associated to
information disclosure when the damage
is already done so maybe after a data
breach has already occurred uh and maybe
we are victim of identity theft
or uh maybe after Cambridge analytica
Scandal exploded um you guys will
remember obviously the case of Cambridge
analytica it started off as
um it's same what what looked like a
simple game on Facebook right people
were answering questions about their
personality on one of those uh
personality tests that are very common
on platforms uh like Facebook uh people
started providing a lot of potentially
uh sensitive information because it was
about their personality
um and this that ended up being shared
with third parties and then used
um allegedly to create uh micro
targeting of political advertising on
the platform uh which is obviously
um quite concerning but we only
discovered this after the fact
um so thanks maybe to the engagement of
the media thanks to documentaries such
as the great hack or the social dilemma
but the damage had already been done and
what researchers have been trying to do
since then is try to understand to what
extent we've been damaged by this right
to try to put a price maybe
um on on these kinds of costs
um but it was already too late so
um asymmetric information is a problem
that is endemic to the the whole data
market and so obviously it prevents us
from
um
managing our privacy effectively so I'll
pause for a second in case there are
questions and then I'll move on to the
second Factor
okay so for no questions
all right if there are just just jump in
guys I really don't mind uh the
interruption
um so the second aspect that I uh
mentioned at the beginning was this idea
that uh technology seems to be taking us
um towards the direction of more and
more uh data collection data sharing
data usage uh data exploitation and this
is because
if we look at this is a small graph so
you obviously cannot read it but it it's
basically just a summary of how much the
cost of a hard drive has decreased over
uh the last 30 40 years or so
essentially the cost of storing data has
declined at an average rate of about an
order of magnitude every five years so
essentially what uh the the hard drive
cost per gigabyte back in the early
1980s was around 100
000 and it's now down to basically just
a couple of cents right it's essentially
free
um so storing data is not really a cost
to companies anymore and
um besides that
um technological progress has created
tremendous opportunities for collecting
data that were basically not available
data that was was never available before
so we have this increasing the
possibilities of data collection we have
decrease in the cost of storage of data
and at the same time we also have
incredible advancements in data
analytics in machine learning and all of
these prediction methods that have
progressed at an unprecedented rate in
the last decade so everything from the
organizational side seems to be leaning
towards more and more data collection
more and more storage and more and I
should say quote better use of data and
again this makes it really difficult for
people to privacy to do their privacy
management correctly because it's
essentially out of their control there's
very little that individuals can do to
prevent for instance more and more
powerful machine learning methods to
predict our preferences based on the
data that is collected there's very
little that we can do about cameras all
over the like all over the being placed
uh all over the city or other kinds of
sensors
um the third aspect economic factor that
I'm going to mention is what some
economists or
researchers of privacy call privacy
calculus it's this idea that to a
certain extent people are pretty good at
understanding what they want to disclose
and what they don't want to disclose
what information they want to share and
what information they don't want to
share they simply evaluate what the
costs and benefits are from a particular
decision and then make a rational uh
decision about this which to a certain
extent it's true the whole literature on
behavioral economics of privacy which
also I've been working on says that this
is really not the whole story and that a
lot of times this is not what happens
but to a certain extent it's true people
uh some of the risks of information
sharing are known to people and so
people make their privacy calculus as
best as they can
um so an indoor goes through the book
called tap back in 2017 and he talks
about all of the economic benefits to
sharing information if we share uh it's
we do it because of convenience we do it
because maybe it allows allows us to
discover new products and services that
otherwise would have not been shown to
us uh sharing information about
ourselves allows us uh to get customized
and personalized products and services
uh maybe we get discounts left and right
so there are lots of economic benefits
from from sharing data and that's a good
thing uh that comes from
um
sharing information and then on the
other hand there is also a ridiculously
high cost from proper privacy management
um if this is really uh it's a very old
paper that came out in 2008 but it
essentially
um
um Alicia McDonald and Lori Craner they
tried to estimate uh what was the annual
opportunity cost for Americans at the
national level to actually read and try
and understand all of the Privacy
policies that people uh you know only
skim through or don't even look at when
they interact with products and services
online and the cost is ridiculously high
I mean we are talking about 800 billion
dollars yearly which is again
ridiculously high so on the one hand we
have lots of benefits from sharing way
ridiculously high costs from privacy
management so people do their math right
there's no point in wasting our time
managing our privacy reading all the
Privacy policies we have lots of
benefits from data sharing so let's
share uh pretty much everything
on top of this all of these technologies
that have been created in the past 20
years or 20 years or so since the
starting of the commercial internet
um have created strong Network effects
so all these platforms two-sided
platforms
um have created essentially lock-in
effects for people so if all of my
friends use one particular platform it
will be extremely costly for me to
switch to another platform which is
maybe more privacy friendly so I'll take
the example of Facebook not because I
want to pick on Facebook but just you
know until 10 years or so I believe it
was the largest social network by far
right now maybe other companies are
doing better than Facebook in terms of
growth even though the general company
is the same I believe Instagram is one
of the uh networks that's growing very
fast right now if all of my friends are
on Facebook it again it will be super
costly for me to switch to something
different that maybe
um I prefer because it is more privacy
oriented did but if nobody's on that new
privacy oriented platform there is
really no use for me to be in it so
there are these strong Network effects
um that basically tilt our privacy
calculus uh towards uh less privacy
friendly uh alternatives
so all these things it's a question oh
yes please please yes
hi Lara thank you um so on um I I wonder
if it's going to come up on the slide
but I'm sort of uh conjecturing that you
don't have any space left so I just want
to add one thing to the Privacy calculus
um it it does seem like a first order
issue is the fact that there's
externalities present in the action of
of sharing the data right so when I so
even if we were perfectly rational and I
could calculate my own benefits when I
give up my data I make it easier to
track Irene for example right and those
costs might be an order of magnitude
bigger than the 780 billion of reading
right which is just kind of dead weight
loss right we can just you know but the
deadweight loss from these sort of bad
prisoners dilemma decisions could be
enormous right absolutely or have people
try to estimate them I guess is the
question
I don't know of papers we have talked
about privacy externalities in our work
uh but I don't think that people have
tried to estimate them uh you know
providing a cost like a price tag to it
but you are absolutely right and I I
agree 100 that there are significant
privacy externalities here and you can
think of privacy externalities from two
at least two uh perspective one is the
one that you mentioned which is uh what
I share uh may affect other people's
privacy
um and so that is one aspect so I don't
incorporate the cost to others of
sharing data
um the other aspect of privacy
externalities is more related to what I
need what I call here these Network
effects so if people are okay with
sharing on Facebook it makes it more
costly to others who are not okay
sharing on Facebook to use other that
are you know other platforms that are
more privacy friendly I'll talk about uh
Twitter and Mastodon later on so I don't
want to spend too much time on it right
now but
um it's only because of very very strong
exogenous shocks that people are
sometimes capable of getting out of
these strong Network effects otherwise
these externalities make it basically
impossible for people to switch uh
platforms because it's just not
convenient to them from an economic
perspective so yes absolutely 100 right
externalities yes
are there any other questions
thank you
there's a few questions yeah I saw two
hands
get your hands have gone back down oh
actually I'll just ask
um
sorry can you just say briefly what the
like action space of people concerned
about privacy here is it's like I use a
platform I don't use a platform I post
uh selfies in my bedroom or uh I put my
address on my academic website like how
are you thinking about uh I know that's
a very basic question but I guess oh
yeah no no I get it and I'm sorry for
the confusion I am being uh very very
I'm staying very very general uh on
purpose because I want to Encompass all
kinds of actions so these might uh
include sure uh sharing uh um
information over social media or
um having an Amazon Echo in your house
or having
um I don't know all kinds of sensors in
your car
um so uh on purpose I'm being very very
generic because all of these concepts
are you know applied to all of these
scenarios uh economic benefits and costs
of information sharing are essentially
applicable to all of those scenarios
you can keep going
oh okay sounds good so let's see I've
talked a little about the economics of
things so let's move on to some
psychology uh as well
um so in a very interesting paper that
was published by carbon and Lowenstein
in 2020
um they were interested in looking at
um the a drive to share so obviously
humans are social animals and there are
very very high benefits from information
sharing uh with each other and in this
paper Carbone and Loans didn't
essentially had this open-ended question
where they were trying to understand why
there is this desire to share this drive
to share and obviously there's tons of
benefits right uh people all of these
percentages that you see here they don't
add up to 100 simply because uh
participants were allowed to provide
multiple selections
um but there's tons of reasons right so
maybe you share with other people
because you want to create an intimate
relationship with them and sharing
achieves intimacy maybe you simply want
to be understood you want to felt uh
understood by the other person and so uh
that's exactly what you're looking for
sharing information about yourself so
that others might understand you better
better
um maybe you just want to receive
comfort you want to make appearance feel
real maybe you want to get advice there
is tons of reasons why uh human beings
have a desire very very strong desire to
share and interestingly I don't have it
on my slide here but there is other
papers in neuro economics that have
looked at uh desired to share and
apparently participants have been
subjected to fmri scans so a scan of
their brains while they were making
decisions about sharing information and
it turns out that when we share
information about ourselves the parts of
the brain are activated that are exactly
the same as the ones that are activated
when we receive a monetary reward
so it's intrinsically rewarding even
from a neurological perspective
um to actually share
um not to mention all the psychological
benefits from uh from from and
physiological benefits from sharing uh
pendant Baker is uh the uh psychologist
that you might be want to look into if
you're interested in uh looking at the
psychophysical
um benefits from sharing so again this
seems to suggest that
um there's uh tons of benefits outside
of the strictly economic benefits
um that come from information sharing so
again it seems to be a nudge towards
towards sharing information rather than
restriction
um another element
um that I should mention is adaptation
um people tend to adapt very very
quickly to whatever level of privacy
they're provided with and there have
been experiments uh so I Jared at all in
2018 they ran a bunch of experiments
that look at uh changing uh privacy
policies and people really uh
um so these these experiments have shown
that people adapt very very quickly to
whatever level of privacy they're
provided with
and so the problem with that is that
these leads to tolerance of low
protections right if we are provided low
protections to be to begin with we are
sort of okay with it and this develops
into what Draper and Tarot called
digital resignation
um digital resignation is this idea that
because we feel that we have zero
control over our privacy we sort of give
up we don't even try
and if you look at digital resignation
it's really it's everywhere it is so
real
um I'll give you just a couple of
examples
um gdpr basically for some companies as
automatically translated into accepting
cookies and so every website that we
visit nowadays asks us to be tracked and
so we do this a million times we are
tired of doing this we want to accept
cookies because we simply want to move
on with our lives we visit our webs
website because we have something to do
on that website not because
um uh our first uh goal is to protect
ourselves from getting cookies and
getting tracked and so yes please accept
cookies
um we are asked every other day to for
you know to sign forms just sign this
form so you know when you go to the
doctor just sign this form because it's
your HIPAA form
um we don't even read it we go ahead and
sign it because we need to get seen by a
doctor
we are the checkout counter and maybe
the cashier asks oh and what's your
email address and what's your phone
number and we don't even think about the
reason why we're asked we simply provide
that information because we've done that
tons of times
um and then we have all these smart
devices and nobody really tells us huh
maybe for the security of these devices
it would be really better if you change
the default password but there's no uh
easy user interface to access and so
we'll have you know maybe I'll just I'll
just forget about it right it's probably
safe hey Amazon is a pretty good company
I should probably trust them to do their
security right and so we don't even do
anything with it we simply surround
ourselves with smart sensors and we
don't change any passwords of any sort
so we have become what uh the great Pink
Floyd would have said you know
Comfortably Numb we don't want to think
about the privacy and security problems
associated with the technologies that we
surround ourselves with we are numb to
it now we are sort of used to low
protections and we feel like we can't do
anything about it we just give up
um and it really sympathize with this I
hope that by the end of the talk I I
will convince those who digitally resign
I hope nobody in the room digitally
resigned but if you did I hope uh to
convince you that there are alternatives
but it is real like I've seen it
um in lots and of different situations
and then there's risk perception
um so the way that humans have evolved
to perceived risk to perceive risk is to
essentially use our senses right so we
use our vision system our auditory
system our olfaction system
um to understand whether something
around us is risky or not the problem is
that more and more of Our Lives occur in
the Digital World online in the cyber
world and in that world it has become
increasingly easy to manipulate and fool
our senses so our risk perception
capabilities which we over Millennia we
have evolved as a human species to use
to detect risk are impaired
um I'll give you just one simple example
of how this might happen
um you might remember this is a visual
cue that I'm going to use okay
um and a manipulation of our visual
system so back in maybe maybe 10 12
years ago this is what our Facebook page
looked like
um this is a very old screenshot of what
Facebook was but the idea is basically
the same Facebook knows who our friends
are and Facebook knows their faces
because most of the times people use
um their faces as their profile pictures
and so let's say that maybe this is one
of my friends
and let's say that this is another one
of my friends you might recognize him
actually Alessandra Christie he happens
to be my PhD advisor and I'm sharing
with permission here
um so maybe what I'm about to show you
maybe it's not what happens but it's
super easy for a company such as
Facebook to do so what happens if we
bring these two faces together this is a
face morph and it's been done with you
know off-the-shelf software it's nothing
fancy you can probably do it with Adobe
Photoshop very easily so the result is a
person that is not really any of my
friends on Facebook but it has actually
none of my friends like I don't know
this person but it's a it's a person
that has traits that are familiar to me
and maybe I associate this face to
people that I trust people that I'm
friends with people that I like
and so what happens if the next
advertisement on Facebook let's say for
a rug is not provided by this random
person but it's provided by this
familiar face someone that I trust right
sorry not someone that I trust but
someone who has traits of people that I
trust
there is tons of literature and
marketing
um that shows that people tend to
respond more positively through
advertisements that come from friendly
familiar faces it's the whole idea
behind having a testimonial right a
famous person behind an advertisement
um so I'm not saying that this happens
but it's
um very very simple right it's a very
very simple manipulation it's a visual
cue which might reassure us and that
might affect our choices and behaviors
online and we don't even realize it
um just to give you a sense of from an
economic perspective of you know the
kind of money that we're talking about
here when it comes to ad expenditure
um this is the most recent data that I
could find but basically Internet Ad
expenditure in the US in 2017 was around
69 billion dollars which was 35 of the
total ad expenditure across all media
which is around 200 billion dollars as
of FDC 2020. so we're talking obviously
you know big money this is not
necessarily uh peanuts but I'm not just
worried about the economics right the
economic factors behind this maybe there
are other ways in which this kinds of
manipulation uh even simple manipulation
like visual cues can affect us
um we already mentioned Cambridge
analytica right so what is the effect of
politically targeted ads on uh
Democratic elections such as the
elections that we've had in the United
States
um in 2016. right
um who's to say that the ads that we saw
on Facebook were not manipulated in ways
that might affect us without our
knowledge of course without consent but
not even with our knowledge so these are
the kinds of ways in which
um our sensorial
um perceptions can be really easily
manipulated and fooled in the online
world
and I have experimental evidence
actually
um to say something about risk
perception uh uh and privacy concerns we
run a bunch of experiments we run four
experiments where we show
um that if you give people cues of the
physical presence of a person around
them or even if you give them visual
cues just uh using their Vision system
uh that a human is present around them
their self-reported privacy concerns
increase so they're sort of like an
alert system that automatically turns on
and it the result is the crease of
disclosure of intimate information in an
online survey
this is true even when the objective
privacy risk is unaltered so I can give
you the visual cue of a human being but
maybe it's in another room so there's no
way that they can possibly peek into the
online survey that you're taking and yet
your privacy concerns will be raised and
your information disclosure will be
decreased
so what this means essentially is that
we use our senses our sensorial systems
right our vision our uh auditory system
our olfactory system to guide us in
defining boundaries between what is
public and what is private and we use
our senses to essentially instinctively
perceive invasions into our private
spheres imagine a feeling that someone
is looking at you right we can perceive
that we call that in our papers a sense
of privacy the problem is that we use
these senses to understand risk around
us but online these senses might be very
easily be easily manipulated just like
the visual cues that I showed you before
and even worse with deep fakes right
there's all these uh deep Fates that
have now uh proliferated and that are
everywhere on the internet which
essentially impair our capabilities to
perceive risks in the online world
I'll pause for another second if there
are questions
before moving on to the next Factor
I guess not
okay great so
um then also talking about psychological
oops sorry
um talking about psychological uh
factors there are also some inherent
biases limitations that are typical of
human decision making one of them we
called it the control Paradox
um this is something that we worked on a
long time ago this is actually the very
first paper I ever published back in
2013 but it I I feel that it's it's very
much relevant even these days
um the idea here is that if people
perceive that they have control over the
sharing of their personal information
they feel safe so they feel less
concerned about their privacy and the
result is that they end up disclosing
more
so this is a graph um you can focus
actually on the left hand side of the
graph
um uh basically I show here
um different
um levels of disclosure for people that
were randomized in different conditions
the red condition here is implicit
control people in this experiment were
asked for personal information and then
they were told whatever you disclose is
going to end up in your social media
profile so we told them that we were
creating a social media profile for the
University
um and so you can see that basically if
you give people only implicit control so
if you tell them whatever you say is
going to be published people are not
that willing to share about 50 of the
item they were willing to disclose
essentially and share but if you start
giving them a little bit more granular
controls they tend to disclose more so
in these next two columns here the wide
column and the Shaded column I'm giving
people explicit control but at the
aggregate level so I'm asking them
questions uh asking them to provide
personal information and then in one box
I tell them uh if tell me if you want to
disclose all of the information that you
provided on your social media and even
this high level this aggregate level of
control makes people less concerned and
more willing to disclose and then last
this left uh left column over here the
blue one it's the most granular form of
control that we gave them of explicit
control that we gave them so again we
asked people for personal information
and then for each of these pieces of
information we ask them do you want to
publish it on your profile or not so as
soon as we gave them this granular level
of control and people felt that they
could really control the sharing of
their information they were okay just
disclosing everything almost 100 of the
items they were willing to disclose so
we don't know if this was uh an
unintended consequence of providing
people with controls but if we look at
how controlled settings in social media
have evolved over times they've become
more and more granular so the result is
that yes people this is great right
people are more in control but the end
result is that they disclose more so
while they might focus on who they're
disclosing to in terms of audience right
creating lists creating groups
separating their personal from their
professional lives they maybe forgot
that the actual platform was anyway
capable of seeing all that information
so shifting people's attention from uh
the uh you know away from the
corporation and more towards the
perceived audience
we call that the control paradox
um another factor is hurting behaviors
so sometimes we don't really know how to
behave when it when it comes to privacy
management right and we try to get cues
about what's the right thing to do from
our environment right so we try to
understand what other people are doing
and we emulate them uh hurting behaviors
and the issue here that makes privacy
management again very very difficult is
that what we see on platforms such as
social media is an infinite scroll of
disclosure it looks like the social Norm
is disclosure right we obviously don't
see what people decide not to disclose
we only see a Continuum of disclosures
so this seems to suggest that hey it's
okay to disclose everything
um so by using these hurting behaviors
again
um these hurting behaviors essentially
push us towards more and more disclosure
and less towards more conscious privacy
management
and another factor is default biases
um so default bias is simply this idea
that people tend to stick with whatever
default they're provided with a little
bit similar with what I suggested when I
talked about adaptation right we have
low uh privacy protection we adapt to it
we have low privacy protection by
default we tend to stick with it
um the idea here is that companies can
easily take advantage of our default
bias right so we don't go out of our way
to change default settings
and one example is what some have
referred to as dark patterns so what I
talked about a minute ago with the
control Paradox
um it was basically a dark pattern but
we didn't call it dark pattern this this
sort of new terminology came up uh
around 2019 and now everybody's
interested in these dark patterns but
all they are really is just
um features of a user interface or of a
platform that affect people's behavior
in ways that tend to be to the advantage
of the platform itself and to the
disadvantage of the user and one example
for instance is this so this is a
company in the UK let's say you're
purchasing a product or or a service you
put it in your basket on the left hand
side here you have the total of your
basket what you're supposed to pay and
then the continue button of course the I
have read terms and conditions should be
checked
um but if you don't click on the more
info button you will actually ever know
that by default you're also subscribing
to all kinds of mailing lists right so
by submitting your details you can send
to us keeping you informed by mail and
email of exclusive offers and services
so this is a particularly pernicious
dark pattern where people are
automatically opting into an email list
without even knowing unless they click
on the more info button
um so it's it's a it's a a very very
dark I would say uh pattern
and then um last but not least uh
emotional reactions so we talked before
about you know this privacy calculus
idea yes to a certain extent people make
rational decisions when it comes to
privacy but it's really difficult to
manage privacy irrationally in an
environment that is full of emotional
stimuli
um so there's research that suggests
that people that are in a positive mood
for instance disclose more more intimate
and more varied information about
themselves well if you look around any
of the platforms that we see online
there's plenty of emotional stimulation
right
um so it's difficult to make a good
informed rational uh privacy decision
um so all of this all of these factors
and again not exhaustive lists there are
other factors seem to be basically
making it totally impossible for us to
do any kind of privacy management so
digital resignation seems inevitable
and yet recently we are seeing signs
that many people are not really ready to
digitally resign there's very
interesting work by Vincent and
co-authors they talk about this
adversarial behaviors people exploiting
their data leverage this idea of data
Leverage is the idea that we as
consumers realize that big corporations
uh that collect data and that create
um data intensive machine learning
algorithms
um they rely on us to provide our data
and we are the ones to provide what some
have referred to as data labor right so
we are the ones who provided so we have
leverage we can go on a data strike for
instance we can stop providing data to
companies we can do data poisoning so
actively manipulating data so that the
data that we provide is inaccurate or we
could contribute data to a competitor
um because maybe you know we have beef
with a particular company that we feel
is not privacy friendly towards us
um so this is the opposite of digital
resignation right so these seem to be
behaviors uh that are suggestive of
people not giving up on their data
simply being taken
um there's also some empirical evidence
that even if people did not have these
adversarial behaviors
um data anyway have diminishing returns
and I'm talking economic jargon again
but what diminishing returns to that I
mean it's simply that
um if you're a company that knows
nothing about their customers the first
few data points are extremely useful to
you so let's say you're building a
prediction model some ml algorithm the
first set of data is super powerful
right it will give you tremendous
Advantage towards knowing nothing
um then you collect more data and your
algorithm becomes better and better but
to a certain point you have enough data
and the marginal benefit that you get by
collecting more data and using more data
to make your algorithm better goes down
and down and down so you have
diminishing returns to collecting and
using data so maybe if that's true as
some recent work suggests both in the
context of Medical Imaging and news
curation maybe amassing and using as
much information as possible may
actually not be optimal for companies
just from an economic perspective
so let's try to turn the impossible now
into possimpable right
um so I have a recipe besides these you
know uh uh
um simply economic uh uh factors there
there are other things that we might do
uh to increase
um the level of
um reaction and to decrease digital
resignation so I'm going to briefly talk
about regulation education and agency
maybe these factors together provide us
um a recipe for uh uh giving us the
essentially the capability to manage our
privacy again
so let's talk a little bit about
regulation first so
um I guess Europe
um started with regulating privacy
um more from a more General perspective
than the US has done in the past by
using gdpr uh the general data
protection regulation which is again
generally enough to Encompass all kinds
of data the current approach which gdpr
has been using and that even local
governments in the United States have
started to use such as California for
instance with cpra they are based on
notice and consent essentially they are
saying that it is the responsibility of
the user to make the right privacy
decisions once they are informed right
so we provide a notice we give people
all the information possible and then we
request for consent it's this idea of
user responsibilization as some have
referred to
but the problem with that approach is
that as I've shown before there are tons
of Behavioral and economic reasons why
user response stabilization is just
unfair people are not put into the
conditions of being responsible for
their own actions it's just not possible
to require such level of
responsibilization from a user
perspective if we think back at what
happens with cars for instance what
happened when technological progress
made cars too dangerous for people to
use it's not that we required people to
for instance we train them to be
to respond faster to stimuli right we
didn't require them to be responsible
for it instead what we did is we made
the technology
um responsible for it so we imposed the
use of ABS on our cars we impose the use
of seat belts we impose the use of
anti-slippery systems so rather than
requiring people to be responsible for
things we help them deal with
technological progress and the argument
here is that maybe rather than
focusing on regulation that only puts
the responsibility on the user
regulation should provide a baseline
protection by default for in instance
by imposing more privacy oriented
behaviors by corporations Maybe by
imposing the use of privacy enhancing
technology such as end-to-end encryption
by default for instance
um so this is a better approach to
regulation which we argue is
basically puts less of the burden on the
user and more of the burden on
corporations organizations which
essentially caused the problem in the
first place
the second ingredient to the recipe is
education so there has been in the last
few years amazing work by computer
scientists HCI researchers they have
created really really powerful
Technologies privacy enhancing
Technologies the problem is that on our
side on the social science perspective
we did terrible marketing about these
pets right privacy enhancing technology
nobody knows about pets and those that
search for instance for private browsing
what they find is this right the logo of
an onion which maybe it's pretty cool
for us who know the exceptional value of
onion routing but it's definitely less
cool than this right if people search
for Amazon Echo this is what they find
uh you know all these interesting
interactive toys right cool design and
the result is that less than one in four
people have been estimated to use vpns
um the market is actually estimated to
the about worth around 800 million
dollars by 2024 versus if we only focus
on one device just the Amazon Echo
device there is about 46 million of
these and if we look at the fourth
generation echo which costs about sixty
dollars that puts Amazon revenues just
for that one product alone to 2.8
billion dollars
so obviously we can't compare right
um uh terrible marketing on privacy
dancing Technologies great marketing on
uh privacy intrusive Technologies sure
they're incredibly useful uh but they're
also privacy intrusive
uh
a quick question yeah
hi this is eloni Cohen
um I
I guess I want to ask
I guess I want to push back a little bit
on the education and I think it just
it's really echoing a question from the
last session which was uh from the back
to the left uh which said uh which was
asking how do you to the Google to the
speaker from Google how do you think
about putting a dollar value on
privacy and I guess my question is like
um
um is it that is it that users don't
can't find these Technologies or learn
how to use them or is it that users
like want the functionality and can't
it's I guess
I guess what's my question my question
is
if you're trying to explain to somebody
and do the education you're trying to
explain to them why they should do the
work
to uh to adopt a pet
um
rather than what are the available pets
or how do they do it but why should they
bother I guess my question is how do you
how do you answer that question because
that seems the hard a hard part of this
education problem
I totally agree and in fact even in our
papers we argue that education on its
own is not going to be enough right so
the first problem is
um uh if if we want to solve it uh the
the first economic problem that I
mentioned which asymmetric information
we have to provide some information to
people we have to educate them about
what are the risks behind using
technologies that do have cool
functionalities but that impose certain
privacy costs that people may not be
aware of so part of it I take it on me
as a social scientist right uh to
actually be responsible for it
um but you're you're perfectly right
that taken on its own education is not
going to be enough that's that's for
sure but I guess what I want to say is
that
um I I put the responsibility on us
social scientists that study privacy
Technologies to make them uh publicly
known and available to people I guess
what I'm saying what I was trying to I
I'll just move on to the next slide
because this is going to help me explain
this to you a little bit little bit
better so these companies that sell uh
products which have very very insanely
useful functionalities they make their
products sexy right if we look at Zoom
for instance what Zoom did even before
covid
um and you know even before before much
of our Lives went you know remote they
want they had a very very simple message
and the message was we want to make
video communication frictionless right
it has to be easy for you to do this it
has to be easy for you to zoom right
it's even become a word right a verb
um so I guess what I'm saying is we
should be as social scientists that
study pets we should be taking uh a
lesson from from this right uh there are
very very good technologies that are
frictionless that provide the same exact
functionality that other Technologies do
but do it in a more privacy friendly
manner we just need to send the message
in the right way okay we need to do
better Marketing in a way we need to
learn from these guys and obviously
I'm not saying that it's something that
is uh you know super easy to do
um this is uh this is because obviously
these companies put a ton of money into
marketing versus you know uh
organizations that create paths you know
alternative uh technologies that are
more privacy friendly they would rather
invest you know in the development of
pets rather than in advertising so there
is obviously a problem there but there
are some good examples right so doctor
go is a good example I want to mention
signal and Mastodon so signal did great
um I guess both signal and Mastodon took
advantage of what I called before you
know very very strong external shocks
right so back in 2021 when WhatsApp
announced the changes in privacy
policies people downloaded signal uh to
you know unprecedented extent we're
seeing the move away from Twitter just
you know now in these days days now that
Elon Musk finalized the acquisition of
Twitter and people are moving to
Mastodon in flocks literally
um so they exploited this exogenous
shocks of things that have happened uh
in the technology space to actually move
to more uh privacy uh friendly
Technologies so it's a hard thing to do
to advertise these products obviously
because cost uh in Mar you know
marketing cost is a major concern for
these companies but I take it on to us
as social scientists to make you know to
push the message a little better
um I I bet all of you guys know all of
these technologies that I mentioned on
this slide but if you don't uh you know
this route is just a platform that
provides all kinds of technologies that
are privacy friendly from communication
Technologies to privacy uh to private
notepads
um alternatives to
um you know Google Documents uh you know
all kinds of productivity tools
um uh that Google for instance provides
there's in videos which is sort of like
an like a Federated alternative to to
YouTube
um all kinds of Technologies right
um so we need I think we need to do a
better job so I'm not putting it onto
the user right I'm not putting the
responsibility to the user that they
should educate themselves about these
alternative paths I'm putting it on to
us I'm saying we are the ones that are
response responsible for this and we
should do a better job and the last
thing that I want to mention because I'm
running out of time is agency that's the
last part of the recipe so if you guys
are familiar with Ethan Zuckerman I'm
sure you are he has a great talk called
the good web it's available online you
can search for it and essentially what
he's saying is people really don't want
to maintain their own Services they
don't want to go away from you know
Amazon web services or from Twitter
Twitter or from you know Facebook to run
their own decentralized server and their
own decentralized system so
decentralization by itself may not work
but again I call it upon institutions
such as universities for instance to
provide Alternatives and here comes our
proposal we call it the digital or with
all project essentially we suggest that
these kinds of decentralized services
that would allow the user to enjoy the
benefits of the technology without
incurring into the costs of a
surveillance and centralization that you
know all the big tech services and
products uh entail we could do it for
them so instances such as next Cloud
instances if you guys are not familiar
again it's um another system to a both
uh store for storage and uh
communication as well
um so we could use we could uh set up
next Cloud instances at local libraries
we could do it at the University level
we could train students and staff to
actually maintain the service so that
the user doesn't have to bother with
managing their own decentralized system
we will do it for them similarly for
secure drop instances
um again I'm sure you're familiar secure
drop is just is this tool that
journalists investigative journalists
use to communicate securely with their
sources they are difficult to maintain
people don't want to do it they may not
have the resources to do it so why not
do it at the institutional level maybe
at the University level local libraries
to provide people with Alternatives that
are just as usable as the commercial
ones but that protect them from
essentially constant surveillance so I
guess the takeaway here is that if if
you don't care about privacy that's fine
but if you do you can help Turn The
Impossible into possible and I know that
I was a lot you know a little fast here
but um I hope that I was able to
convince at least some of you guys that
privacy management is possimpable
so I'll just stop here and and uh and
take a few questions if there are
so much Laura thank you
hi my name is Juan Tong I have a
question there's a rule in gdpr called
right to be forgotten so as a user can I
ask a company to delete some data that
as you said that when company
accumulated many and many and many data
points the value will
will diminish so can I ask a company to
just keep about 30 days data to achieve
some efficiency and privacy yeah very
good question yes so what you can do as
a European resident I don't know if
you're a resident of the EU but if you
are a resident of the EU what you can
request is
um for your data to be taken down but
whether or not the request is uh
satisfied that's a different matter
um so uh the right to be forgotten was
uh essentially the the Wrath the ratio
right the the reason for the law is that
there is uh information about us out
there which is probably outdated which
might affect
um our social interactions uh think of
for instance uh very very old criminal
records that might affect our capability
to you know take a job you know stuff
like that so those are things that are
outdated inaccurate and that might have
an effect in our social lives so you can
do the request to companies to take that
information down but companies are not
required to do so so it's up to them
essentially to decide whether or not
to take it down and if they decide not
to you can try to sue by proving that
you that that information still being
out there out there caused harm to you
but it becomes a very very painful
process right so it's not easy and it's
not
um you know it's not implementable with
just a simple request that you would you
know do to Google but people have tried
so if you're interested in this uh
follow Max schremps who's the guy who
essentially sued uh Facebook a bunch of
times and also essentially fought for
um a better agreement between the US and
Europe when it comes to sharing that
across the Atlantic so he's the guy
behind the privacy Shield 2 2.0 for
instance so but it's a very interesting
legal debate
thanks for the talk Laura this is shuchi
I wanted to ask you about the role of
Regulation uh so you you know presented
a very convincing case that gdpr style
regulation is not very effective it has
you know limited use but on the other
hand you know auditing uh is uh the you
know in my sense you know not very
effective either because of the extent
to which uh you know it would be
required uh
uh right and so do you see a middle
ground here for regulation uh then how
what what do you think that might look
like effective regulation
yeah so
um I uh what we are trying to push with
our research is essentially a type of
Regulation that sets minimum boundaries
of protection let's put it that way so
um it shouldn't be left completely to
the user
um to be responsible for their privacy
protection people should have some sort
of what some people have called it
privacy by default right and they have
tried to incorporate uh this principle
in software development in um actually
development of both software and
Hardware
um and the idea is that
um by default privacy should be
protected and then if people want to
share more it's up to them to decide so
um so what we are trying to suggest here
is so the middle ground would be let's
use regulation in order to force privacy
by default at the structural level so
you know when you design an
infrastructure when you design uh either
software or Hardware infrastructure it
has to have privacy embedded in it it
shouldn't be an afterthought and it
shouldn't be the responsibility of the
user uh to take care of it it should be
guaranteed by default and this obviously
uh met a lot of pushback right from
companies
um so sorry yes just one second because
my battery is dying I'm just gonna plug
in my uh sorry just one second
happened
sorry I didn't want to lose you
um so um there there's a lot of pushback
right from companies because it is not
convenient for corporations and
organizations to have privacy embedded
right privacy by default and the problem
with all the regulation that we've seen
up to now is what some legal Scholars
and some economists have called
regulatory capture right so if you are a
company that has vested interests in
data collection and the usage and data
exploitation you're going to want to
make sure that you have a say in how the
regulation is written so that it doesn't
necessarily put you at a disadvantage
right so
um I believe that the way that
regulation has been created
um has in a way
made it very easy for companies to get
around it right so notice and consent is
basically getting around basic Baseline
privacy protection and instead what
we're arguing is that regulation should
be written and implemented in a
different way uh which is privacy by
default you know using uh privacy
announcing technology by default
I don't know if that answers your
questions that's a very good question
uh Laura thank you so much um I'm
wondering if we're kind of being a bit
timid here a social scientist I mean if
we recognize that there's huge
externalities to
um uh giving up your data uh there's
kind of addiction issues that you talked
about there's all these kind of defaults
and cues and all these behavioral things
there's Market power it seems like you
know we've we've got to go beyond kind
of gentle education and setting the
right defaults right and we sort of know
what the economic instruments for this
stuff is so if like the quantity of data
that you collect is a good proxy for how
bad it is in terms of privacy why don't
we just tax data quantities so I I'd
like I realize it's obviously imperfect
and exactly how data is used but you
know like in a way that would actually
push companies to collect the data they
actually need to provide the products
that they need right and so we know
right if if there is a cost to it
there's nothing wrong in principle with
just taxing it and you know in the same
way as we tax cigarettes right I mean
cigarettes are basically the same as
data right I mean you it's just you know
and and actually it's it's it's even
more than that right I mean we've made
it socially unacceptable to smoke we
should make it socially unacceptable to
give up your data because it's not just
about you right so I mean I guess we're
very far beyond we're at a stage where
people still think smoking is cool right
because you just kind of it's okay to
give up your data So eventually we'll
get to a place where some people will
think smoking is not cool that's still
not enough right because there's passive
smoking that's the bit that kind of the
externalities uh bit that we discussed
at the beginning but you know if we just
increase the price of cigarettes
kind of is going to take us there right
but I don't sort of you didn't mention
this instrument it doesn't seem like a
lot of people talk about this is there
something kind of profoundly wrong with
this idea
thank you for the great question
um so I I do believe that people have
talked about this a lot actually
um so if you look at all of the systems
um
um that have been created for I think
they're called pods uh right now so the
idea here is to create data vaults right
so imagine that you
um put all of your data in uh in a vault
it's protected and then you are the one
who decides when the Vault gets opened
and it gets open for a price right so
companies will whenever they access the
Vault they have to pay a price
um
it has been talked a lot actually and
and there are systems now to do to do it
the problem that I see with it is
um it's it's two sets of problems one is
that the uh only way that such a system
can be successful is for data that is
static right so data that you can
literally close inside a vault right
maybe by Vault I mean I don't know
encrypt it in some way and provide you
know decryption uh uh Services only to
to those who request and pay for it
um but the problem is that uh a lot of
the data that is used for instance for
targeting or you know for tracking it's
Dynamic data it's data that changes over
time and it's data that gets created as
you go about your life right it's not
something that you can enclose in a
vault and then that you can give people
access to
um that's the actually that's the most
useful data and that's the one for which
a model like the data would work it's
just not applicable because it's Dynamic
and it changes the other reason why I
think this is problematic is that it
Crea it might create all kinds of
inequities if we think about privacy
just as something that is uh based on
monetary exchanges uh it we might end up
favoring those that are capable of doing
uh better uh bargaining
um you know I'm
I'm better able to price my data
correctly so I'm going to get a better
deal on it
um uh so I'm just uh I'm a little bit
afraid that if we only talk about the
price of data we might end up
diminishing the what we call dark matter
of privacy so the privacy in intrusions
that are very very difficult to quantify
right and that we can't put a price on
um how do you put a price on a fair
Democratic elections right that's
something that's super difficult to do
at the societal level but even at the
individual level how do you price
um the value of this personality test
that you took on Facebook you know five
years ago or something like that so
pricing privacy is problematic on its
own so these are some of the things that
we should think about when we discuss
models of Taxation of data taxation but
yes I do agree with you people have
talked about it a lot and they've tried
to implement it to a certain extent it's
just that it hasn't taken off because I
think in part uh some of these issues
that I mentioned
but yeah
thank you so much Laura with that I
think we are at time
um
um so staying Gloria again
thank you so much guys
this was great thank you sorry I wasn't
able to be there in person but it was
lovely to talk to you that's great
um and for everyone else we now have
lunch and uh please be back here at two
o'clock two o'clock all right bye
everyone thank you